erica's with us in fort lauderdale hey
erica what's up
hi dave hi ken uh first of all thank you
so much
dave you changed me in my husband's life
no you did i'm proud of you
oh thank you um so my husband and i um
we are our question is whether we keep
our house or not
we we actually are in ministry we live
overseas um right now in the caribbean
and and basically uh we are we have a
house in fort lauderdale
and we're fully supported by churches
so um but the thing with our house right
now is it
um we're planning to stay where we are
maybe for the next five to nine years
we've come to that decision
so we have this house in fort lauderdale
and
it needs a new roof insurance isn't
paying for it so we can't go through
that
um it's south florida so taxes are
really high and we're learning about all
this we didn't realize this with taxes
and everything
and so we're just considering selling it
yes um
yes okay today
wow this thing's not a blessing it's a
curse
it's not bringing you peace yeah that's
true it's not it's not adding to your
life
can you make money on it yeah they'll
make money on it
you make money on can't you when you
sell it yeah yeah yeah dave yeah yeah i
just wanted to confirm that i mean so
think about put some money in the bank
to ensure
that to ensure that your missionary
endeavor doesn't run up underfunded at
some point
yeah and you know all the missionaries
keep this is a problem as all the
missionaries tell us
and we just witnessed it don't tell your
house like this is the thing with
missionaries
they they don't have anything when they
go back so they're like don't sell your
house whatever you do so i think a big
part of us is like
if we sell it you know we don't want
that money that
well i i disagree with that sentiment
and i have told missionaries that for 30
years
that is a wrong statement you should
sell your house if you're going to be
gone five years you should sell your
house it take the proceeds
and take whatever you would have spent
on a house payment and
invest it in good mutual funds so that
you have a nice house fund
to buy a home when you come home
but the idea that you need to keep your
property and try to be a long-distance
landlord
while you're trying to serve jesus in
the caribbean that is just dad gum hard
that just adds pain to your life not
blessings yeah scarcity versus abundance
you you're not going to be homeless when
you come back yeah you can especially
you need to have a plan to have a home
when you come back now that part
that's what's driving them to make the
statement of never sell your house
because they're afraid they're
not going to have the money to buy a
house because they've never saved
anything
so if you don't plan to have a home when
you come back
by investing then you then then you've
made a real mistake
but you need to plan by continuously
investing to be ready to return
let's run the numbers out on that dave
because i think it was great advice i
mean just a ballpark number let's say
they make 100 grand on their house or
150 and they put it in a mutual fund she
said they're going to be there five to
nine years
she puts in a good mutual fund that
becomes that housing fund if all of
their other expenses on the mission
field are covered
that becomes a sizeable down payment
it'll double yeah
it'll double in about seven years that's
the narrative again that's not happening
yeah but if you take that money and
spend it to live on the mission field
and you have
zero money and zero house and you come
off yeah
that's the fear that has created this
thing oh never sell your house when you
go in this field
now if you're going to mission field for
six months that's a different thing
these people are gonna be gone five
seven years ten years whatever so that's
a different that changes the equation as
well